[indistinct radio chatter]
- Sheriff's department!
Frisbee!
(Garcia)
'Chandler, Ross, Joey'
'Oliver, Greg,
get in the house!'
'Get in the house!'
(Garcia)
'How are we doin' today?
How are we doin'?'
We got a call down there
at the department
uh, some, uh, aircraft
takin' off from, uh,
Reno airport's been receivin'
some, uh, fire,
some, uh, bullet rounds.
(Frisbee)
'What airline was it?'
(Garcia)
Uh...
Doesn't really matter, Frisbee,
honestly...
I don't shoot at airlines.
Alien aircraft.
(Garcia)
'You only shoot at
alien aircraft?'
What I think is alien aircraft,
ET stuff.
(Garcia)
Uh-huh, how would you
distinguish that
from regular aircraft?
It's got aliens in it.
What if you start [beep]
spirits, uh, aircraft?
What if they were just, you
know, doin', a little, uh
drive by and you start, uh,
takin' shots at 'em
'and suddenly, holy [beep]'
we just took a first shot
at an alien spacecraft?
That's a good question.
What's your name?
- 'Travis, Travis Jr.'
- Travis.
Travis, that's a good question.
Thank you.
- I like your look.
- I like your, uh, lifestyle.
(Frisbee)
'Thanks a lot.'
Got a nice house, got a good,
good wife, second cousin.
- 'How you doin', ma'am?'
- Hi, I'm good, thanks.
If we were to look,
say, for example
'in that bunker
that you covered with tarp'
'right before we came over...'
I ain't been in there
for so long
I have not,
I haven't been over there--
You never make it
to this corner of the yard.
- That's not even ours.
- This is not yours?
- Oh... Honey, is that ours?
- Shut up!
- I'm sorry.
- 'Oh.'
- Oh, ho ho ho ho!
- Oh, my lord!
[police laughing]
(Garcia)
'Wow! Oh, Frisbee!'
(Frisbee)
'Yeah, I got this
at a yard sale.'
What? [beep].
I never find [beep].
(Jones)
'You got a bargain too.'
You're just shootin'
at these cans right there?
'That and the oranges.'
- Alright, so just cock her up.
- 'Just hug up to it.'
Alright, put the hand
underneath. Here we go.
- Whoo-hoo!
- Feed and bleed!
- Alright, here we go.
- Let it feed and bleed!
[gunshots]
- 'Oh!'
- 'That's it!'
[explosion]
That was pretty [beep] cool.
- Can I do it next?
- Sure, go ahead.